okay listen I ain't no sound scientist
but that's not how sounds sound like
let's get a quick rundown of what's
Happening Here person records slow-mo
footage and therefore any audio of
captured events can be slowed down the
same way video can well I mean okay yes
it can but it would sound like
this so they decided to create their own
sound effects for the sake of the video
I'm fine so but like what are these
sounds that they're creating does
someone on their team really think
poking a grape with a needle sounds like
this or that drinking a fresh thing of
juice sounds like
this am I reading way too much into this
probably will I continue to be grumpy
about it regardless you bet your ass I
will